have you ever really thought much about
Han Solo's rank the rebellion general
solo lots general really the last time
the rebellion saw Han Solo before this
he was planning to bail on everyone he
decided to stay then he gets frozen in
carbonite for a year gets forgiven and
immediately gets promoted to general
what how does that even make any sort of
sense
no wonder the rebellion ends up with
such tactical genius as his vice admiral
hold oh I wonder how long she spent in
carbonized
[Music]
hello Internet welcome to film Theory
last chance to hop into an escape pod if
you want to avoid spoilers for solo and
well the entire Star Wars franchise
because not only are we heading straight
into the asteroid field of movie plot
points but this theory might actually
spoil Han Solo for you as a character
across the Star Wars universe but hey
you won't be alone as a fellow Star Wars
fan over here I was as excited about Han
Solo prequel as anyone and that was
about like I'm kind of excited about
this but after watching it I was left
with no choice I had to come to terms
with the only conclusion you can about
han Solo the handsome hunky space cowboy
we all once knew and had confusing
feelings about is actually nothing but
an overhyped poser that's right the
quote-unquote best pilot in the galaxy
is nothing but a credit stealing Lackey
whose success in the entire Star Wars
franchise is a complete and total farce
Han Solo is a lie period and a story he
knocks and it's all thanks to what we
see in the prequel are you still there
okay great for the 12 of you who didn't
rage quit this video after me saying all
of that first off I'm gonna prove that
everything I just said is true and
secondly I'm gonna make a believer out
of you two on with the theory since
apparently none of you went to see solo
in theaters I'll catch you up on this
completely predictable plot of this
latest movie young Han Solo starts the
movie by escaping his crappy home planet
but hopes he leaves his kaliciak me
girlfriend Kyra nope not that one either
Kyra behind after debating whether to
abandon her for less time than it took
me to say the sentence
he's like peace I'm out of here hun
first goes to the Imperial service but
as snooty highbrow thief he finds the
work distasteful so he runs away and
becomes a smuggler after completely
ruining his smuggler mates business
prospects and going off
thousand of them in the process he wins
the Millennium Falcon from Lando in a
card game Lando and his highly
progressive droid l 337 go with Han on a
mission to retrieve a MacGuffin I mean a
hyper evolved energy source and in the
process they complete the legendary
Kessel run in less than 12 parsecs so
this all sounds like yet another fun and
wacky Star Wars adventure so why am I
going so hard on Han well this movie is
supposed to establish to us why Han has
such an amazing reputation as a pilot
and a smuggler by the time we reach the
original Star Wars trilogy but if you
actually look at the movie then go back
and even look at episodes 4 through 6 of
the original trilogy you can see that
Han actually sucks at all those things
roll the tape
everything starts when you see him at
the opening of solo where by the way
he's not a pilot yet and doesn't have
experience flying anything but some
measly hovercraft they make that very
clear in the opening moments and the
early scenes of the movie show that he's
not even good at handling those
hovercraft the only thing we know he
does successfully is Hotwire a hover car
which means that he's skilled enough to
have watched about two YouTube videos on
how to hotwire something yes those
videos exist and no you shouldn't watch
them for anything but educational
purposes once we see him steal a vehicle
he cruises away in a classic Star Wars
style chase scene and this becomes the
first moment where we see his great
piloting skills put to the test he goes
in for the classic thread the needle
maneuver he would later be known for and
completely fails he biffed sit he
crashes the ship is ruined but okay I
hear you saying it already this movie is
to show him growing he can't start off
being amazing at everything the Karate
Kid doesn't backs off perfectly his
first time either
and I hear you I understand that I went
into this movie expecting that but what
if I told you that Han never learns to
fly that this level of piloting
ineptitudes where Han starts and where
he stays for all the rest of his time
alive don't believe
let's keep going after we establish the
humps exit flying at the beginning of
the movie we watch him continue to suck
the next time he gets a chance behind
the wheel or I guess cleans don't have
wheels so the next time he takes the
stick doesn't sound right either you
gotta really come up with some better
piloting metaphors
anyway we see Han joined the imperial
army expecting to learn to fly
but we then fast forward three years and
he's a boots on the ground Grande he's
not a pilot he was expelled from flight
schools checked outside Academy we never
actually get a sense of how much
training he receives but based on what
we see next it could have been much the
next time we see Han fly is with his
smuggler friend back in I'm putting
together a crew you ran which if you
seen the movie can't really be called a
success while trying to steal hyper fuel
from a train they're attacked by summer
otters on flying motorcycles their
getaway driver is shot and killed
leaving Han in the pilot's seat and
what's our ace flyer to do he literally
runs into the side of a mountain with
two or three motorcycle riders to his
left he doesn't think to I don't know
turn right and instead runs himself
headlong into the mountain dropping the
hyper fuel leaving the mission a
complete disaster with two people dead
and literally nothing to show for it
goodbye mission goodbye smuggler money
and thanks a lot han Solo and just to
reiterate we're 45 minutes into the
movie at this point and there is still
no learning curve on Hans piloting
abilities han hasn't learned anything
about being a pilot or a smuggler for
that matter between the first scene and
now in fact his piloting is just more
deadly and more costly than it ever has
been but I know you Star Wars fans are
really persistent and you're still
making arguments here that none of these
early scenes matter because by the end
of the movie han is an amazing pilot
he's your man crush Monday and there's
nothing I can say to change your mind
well let's just look at that supposedly
amazing Kessel run from the end of the
movie and in the meantime prepare for
your man crush to be totally crushed man
let's look at how the Kessel run goes
down in typical Han style he promises
that he can retrieve raw completely
unstable hyper fuel from Kessel which is
a planet that just so happens to be a
hop skip and a jump through a maelstrom
that's unnavigable for most pilots but
not for all ha
or should I say not for Lando and l3 37
and here's where Hans piloting really
starts to unravel let's talk about l3 37
the robo justice warrior whose name
alone is just pure cringe since it's a
bunch of movie execs trying to be cool
by naming their robot and leet-speak
according to Lando one of the reasons l3
is so advanced and eccentric is the fact
that she hasn't had her memory wiped in
years the advantage to this gives her is
that now she has a vast navigational
record that serves as the most detailed
and nuanced map in the galaxy such
incredible records not only allow l3 to
travel efficiently but also let her to
make maneuvers through dangerous poorly
charted areas like asteroid fields or in
the case of our Kessel run the Maelstrom
she's in charge of overseeing the
navigation of the Millennium Falcon
safely through the Maelstrom on the way
to Kessel which she does without even
flexing but then on Kessel something
unexpected happen namely everyone on
board becomes a social justice warrior -
well on Kessel l3 37 tries to free her
fellow robots from an eternity of
servitude but gets shot the process just
when she's about to go offline
permanently Lando uploads her data into
the Millennium Falcon to save her AI and
bolster the ship's navigational
abilities in the process linking her
consciousness with the ship forever and
this this is the linchpin in exposing
Han Solo's lies we now have a droids
consciousness linked with the Millennium
Falcon specifically a piloting droid
with what's established as the most
robust navigational knowledge in the
galaxy it's only after this point that
we see han Solo actually perform
impressive piloting maneuvers and you'll
notice it's only ever in the Millennium
Falcon don't believe me look at this at
the end of solo we see Han finally pull
off his signature thread the needle
maneuver will Ken's his failure with the
move earlier on in the movie with the
hover cars and is meant to show the
growth of his skills rights he then goes
on to do it twice more throughout the
series first and the Empire Strikes Back
while he navigates the asteroid and then
again even more famously to escape the
cave
but here's the thing it's not him
pulling off those maneuvers its l3 we
know this not because we see him being a
terrible pilot later but because we see
plenty of other characters who are
definitely not pilots suddenly becoming
amazing at flying as soon as you put him
at the helm of the Millennium Falcon in
Return of the Jedi filming witch-hunt
never pilots the Falcon on-screen Lando
gets a hold of the Falcon and pulls off
multiple close maneuvers including the
same thread the needle move getting
through the core of the second Death
Star and in case you think that Lando
might have perfected the move in the
time that he owned the ship how about
someone who has never flown before
period when Rey flies the Falcon for the
first time in her life she manages to
pull off the same exact move and then
again a few weeks later on crate she
does it one more time for good measure
and we know it can't be Ray's parents
passing on good piloting skills since
you know Chelsea jumped treasures that's
one that's gonna come back and bite him
a couple times with my theories of
anything to say about it long story
short the common thread through all of
this it's not the pilot skills eats the
ship the ship with L 337 the most
advanced piloting droid in the galaxy
built into its system ray may not
realize how much the Falcon is actually
helping her out but Han certainly knows
have you ever stopped to notice how Han
is rarely the person flying when the
ship is under attack in Episode four he
actively gives up piloting to Chewie so
he could have more fun I mean be more
helpful by hopping into one of the
turret in Episode five neither hot nor
Chewie are in the cockpit with the
Falcon is actively under Imperial fire
but the shift somehow manages to come
out unscathed and how about all those
times that Han talks about his evasive
maneuvers
I know a few maneuvers yeah flying in a
straight line real evasive there Han
you'll notice that he does this while
the navigational system ie l3 is busy
charting a hyperspace routes safe enough
to make the jump to hyperspace let's
face it his name should be Han didn't do
it solo honestly considering the origin
of his name aim Solo wouldn't be much
dumber ladies and gentlemen of the
internet I'm sorry to dash your dreams
of hunky Han the great star pilot but
hey if you have your heart set on
becoming a great pilot like Han Solo
when you grow up now you know that even
without stepping foot in a cockpit
you've probably already hit benchmarks
since let's face it the bar is pretty
darn low the only question this theory
leaves me with is what I'm gonna leave
you with now - did the film makers know
I mean I hate to say it but this theory
is backed up with a lot of evidence
across the movies so much so that I
would actually speculate that the makers
of solo may have known what they were
doing here I mean think about it the
whole movie plays up this idea that l3
is a liberated droid and she's a cocky
pilot she's too good for Lando's
advances and she takes it upon herself
to liberate all droids in the Star Wars
universe and that jams up literally
buried in the wiring of the Millennium
Falcon in the mean time han Solo a human
who never accomplishes anything without
her help gets all of the credit for her
work spending the next three movies
bragging about all his amazing flying
abilities did Lucas and Disney intend to
show how incredibly unfair the situation
is I don't know but if so man that makes
me like this movie a whole lot more and
with how much I really didn't like the
movie that helps a lot but hey that's
just a theory a film theory
and cut
you